von crafter du kennst mich klar du hast
doch bei minecraft megaprojekt dabei
stimmt ist aber schon eine weile her
ich bin nicht mehr ganz auf dem neuesten
stand ich war eine zeitlang im
krankenhaus hallo ich meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen zu einer
kleinen vorstellung sandler games im
hintergrund links booms und zwar habe
ich ja damals schon mal ein video
gemacht über einen minecraft buch was
ich ganz geil fand also das hieß
zurück in die würfel welt bzw damals ist
glaube ich würfel wenn irgendetwas
stimmt nicht mit jeder welt in der sich
marco unvermittelt wieder befindet ohne
zu wissen wer ist und wie er hierher kam
erst nach einem moment erkennt ja was
ihn stört alles um ihn herum besteht aus
würfeln ja ab jetzt gerade schon kleinen
ausschnitt gesehen und zwar hat mich der
autor also der autor heißt karl olsberg
oder holzberg hat mich per mail
angeschrieben und meinte hey das ist
richtig cool das video dazu dass mein
buch in deinem video erwähnt hast und
das war irgendwie auch in der amazon
bestenliste und alles mögliche und das
haben sich echt richtig viele von euch
gekauft das finde ich richtig cool und
es fand er auch richtig cool
deswegen meinte er zu mir hey hast du in
welche ideen fürs neue buch möchtest du
dass ich eine zweite auflage machen soll
ich dich erwähnen und so war es alles
und ich fand's natürlich mega geil und
habe ihn positiv geantwortet und ich
habe jetzt hier sein vorweg abzug
geschickt bekommen so sieht das cover
aus zurück um sich hier ein spiegel
willmandingen ziehe meine pc dann oft
die auch das heißt zurück in die würfel
welt und weil der erste wurde anhalt
würfel wälder ist das ist ein
ihr seht es schon ein minecraft roman
meine damen und herren also wenn ihr
minecraft liebt dann holt euch dieses
buch was ist jetzt hier nur eine vor
abfassung des ist sondern hier sind wie
sondern wie so eine broschüre halt
einfach das richtige buch ist allerdings
schon draußen kann man auch schon kaufen
ich habe euch den link einfach mal in
die kommentare gepackt ganz in die
beschreibung die in die kommentare
ganz oben und zwar ich bekomme dafür
erst mal gar nichts dafür dass sie
irgendwie sage ich mache das nur weil
ich ihn unterstützen möchte weil ich die
bücher echt geil finde ihr habt wohin ja
schon einen ausschnitt aus dem aus man
vor damaligen video über die das erste
den ersten mal von ihm gehört
ich möchte euch jetzt auch ein wenig
hier raus vorlesen und zwar ich fange
jetzt mal an ich lese ich erst mal die
seite eins vor und dann das kapitel wo
ich drin vorkommen und vielleicht einen
kleinen einblick zu geben aber es ist
auf jeden fall richtig richtig geil oder
auch das fanden wir das kapitel
richterin ist ein bisschen verwirrend
aber witzig also wenn es euch wirklich
interessiert dann wünscht euch das zu
ostern oder keine ahnung ich weiß ist
ostern egal willst du nicht doch lieber
noch ein paar tage zu hause bleiben
meine mutter sieht mich sorgenvoll an du
bist ziemlich blass
mir geht es gut mit einem lächeln
versuche ich zu überspielen dass ich
immer noch etwas wacklig auf den beinen
bin wenn man vier wochen im koma lag ist
das ganz normal nehme ich an
aber um nichts in der welt will ich
heute zu hause bleiben jetzt wo amelie
wieder da ist während ich noch im
krankenhaus lag ist sie mit ihrer mutter
zu ihrer großeltern gefahren den
irgendeinem kleinen kaff in den bergen
wohnen sie braucht mich jetzt hat sie
gesagt und ich habe genickt als macht es
mir nichts aus sie zwei wochen lang
nichts zu sehen
wir haben jeden tag miteinander
gechattet manchmal mehrere stunden lang
aber das ist nicht das selbe du bist so
tapfer ich bin stolz auf dich mein sohn
nahm gibt mir einen kuss zum abschied
das ist auch durch dasselbe ein kalter
nieselregen wenn die letzte müdigkeit
aus dem gesicht es tut gut wach zu sein
meine schule liegt nur einen kilometer
von seinem elternhaus entfernt während
ich den gewohnten weg entlang schlendere
wandern meine gedanken zurück in die
seltsame welt in einem kopf in der ich
gefangen war
bisher habe ich niemanden von meinen
erlebnissen erzählt nicht einmal amelie
ich will nicht dass sie mich für
verrückt wird
außerdem hat sie noch nie minecraft
gespielt und keine ahnung was triton
endermann sind doch jetzt wünschte ich
ich könnte meine eindrücke und
erlebnisse mit ihren teil
es fühlt sich alles immer noch so real
an als wäre ich wirklich dort gewesen
orientierungslos am würfel strand von
skeletten gehetzt in einer dunklen höhle
ratlos im raum mit den vielen hebeln
voller ehrfurcht vor dem thron des todes
in todesangst in der düsteren halle des
winters verzweifelt auf dem rücken des
ende brachen seit ich aus dem
krankenhaus kam habe ich nicht mehr am
computer gespielt
ich weiß selbst nicht genau warum
vielleicht hatte ich angst dass es mir
mein lieblingsspiel keinen spaß mehr
machen würde
nachdem ich jetzt so real erlebt habe
möglicherweise habe ich auch einfach das
bedürfnis gehabt die ganz normale
langweilige realität zu genießen von
aufregenden abenteuern hab ich
jedenfalls erstmal genug
als ich mich dem schulgelände nähere
bekomme ich auf einmal eine riesen
bammel was euch zusammen die sagen
einfach hallo ist das nicht ein bisschen
wenig solche einen kuss geben
wir haben uns geküsst als ich aus dem
koma aufgewacht bin aber was wenn das
bloß dankbarkeit war weil ich sie von
ihren bösen stiefvater befreit habe
vielleicht hat sich während unserer
stundenlang jets in wirklichkeit
gelangweilt mal ehrlich was könnte ein
mädchen wie sie schon an einem typen wie
mir finden vielleicht möchte sie das
wäre vor nur gute freunde bleiben mein
herz pocht bis zum hals mein kopf ist
wie leergefegt als ich schließlich das
schulgelände betreten
als erster kommt
grinsen entgegen marco mann du hast uns
allen ganz schönen schrecken eingejagt
also das war die erste seite davon gibt
es in dem buch
annähernd 100 700 707 ich weiß nicht wie
das nachher ist das wird ja nachher
zusammen taschen bedrucken
den habe ich zwar auch schon aber der
liegt bei mir oben und ich weiß ich habe
nicht genau wie viele seiten der adler
ich das hier halt gelesen habe wenn ihr
da wirklich bock drauf habt auch so eine
story dann dann klingt wirklich auf den
ersten link in der beschreibung oder auf
einen der ersten ich weiß nicht an und
kommt es euch wenigstens mal an ich
meine könnte ja da glaub ich sogar ein
textauszug lesen ich sag jetzt mal ein
bisschen außer dem artikel hier vor wo
ich darin vorkomme das ist vielleicht
ein bisschen komisch für euch jetzt hier
diese ganzen chronologische reihenfolge
aber egal
ratter ratter ta ta ta ta ta die
schienen klappert unter der loro wäre
nicht durch ein von fackeln beleuchtet
das bergwerk haase emmely sitzt in einer
zweiten loren und parameter vor mir ich
versuche mich ihr zu nähern doch sie hat
mit derselben geschwindigkeit durch den
stollen wie ich die schienen knicken
plötzlich in steilem winkel nach unten
ab meinen magen rebelliert als ich für
einen moment nahezu schwerelos bin
amelie rufe ich an die halter an ich
muss mit dir reden doch entweder hört
sie mich nicht oder sie ignoriert mich
absichtlich wir kommen eine weiche
amelie biegt links habe ich selbst
gerade raser aus ich selbst rasen
geradeaus seite wie ist das möglich da
war auch kein schalter oder ich sehe wie
sie sich ein paar blöcke von mir
entfernt bevor ihre strecken rechtskurve
macht jetzt raten wir parallel durch
eine riesige unterirdische höhle amelie
brülle ich so laut ich kann sie dreht
den kopf zu mir erst jetzt erst jetzt
wird mir bewusst dass sie nicht wie eine
micro figur aussieht ist ein ganz
normaler mensch mit einer würfe welt ein
sehr trauriger mensch sie sagt etwas was
darauf ruft sie zu mir ich verstehe
nicht was jemand habe aber auch keine
zeit darüber nachzudenken
als ich wieder nach vorne sehe erkenne
ich dass wir beide auf einen tiefen
abgrund zu rasen an dessen grundlage
buddelt während ihr schienenstrang auf
einer brücke weiter führt endet mein
abrupt in der mitte der schlucht war auf
marco ruft sein letztes mal wach auf ich
will etwas antworten irgendwas doch die
kilos mehr zugestimmt als meinen ohren
in freien abgrund stürzt worauf man was
ich schrecke hoch mein wagen kreml meine
wange grimmelt ich habe ziemlich
unmöglich mit dem kopf gegen das fenster
gelehnt ein junger typ sitzt mir
gegenüber noch ein paar jahre
als ich er hat braunes haar das er nach
oben gekämpft hat ich habe das gefühl
ihn zu kennen kann mich aber nicht an
ihr kann mich aber nicht erinnern woher
tut mir leid wenn ich dich geweckt habe
aber ich dachte die geht es vielleicht
nicht gut du hast so komisch gestöhnt
was entschuldige ich habe schlecht
geträumt ich sehe auf die uhr
erleichtert stelle ich fest dass ich nur
eine gute stunde geschlafen habe das ist
noch genug zeit bis zum zielbahnhof
kenne ich sagt er und wendet sich wieder
dem laptop auf seinen knien zu seine
figuren seine finger klappern in
beeindruckender geschwindigkeit drauf
herum bilder meines traums ziehen durch
meinen kopf bla bla bla bla entschuldige
ich dein t-shirt des spiels minecraft er
grinst klar du auch ich weiß nicht was
ich darauf antworten soll ich kann ja
schlecht erzählen dass ich vor kurzem 8
dachte tatsächlich in der minecraft welt
zu leben also nicht bloß ich mache let's
play videos auf youtube erzählt er du
weisst was das ist nämlich an
jetzt weiß ich wie sehr mir vorkam von
crafter du kennst mich klar du hast doch
bei minecraft megaprojekt dabei stimmt
ist aber schon eine weile her
ich bin nicht mehr ganz auf dem neuesten
stand ich meine zeit lang im krankenhaus
oh was ernstes ich hatte einen unfall
eine weile bewusstlos aber jetzt geht
die besser jakob schon wieder dieser
fällt mit blick auf die gangwahl blabla
also da komme ich drin vor ein kapitel
11 es wäre schon genug wenn euch das
buch einfach kauft wegen meinem kapitel
spaß wenn es euch gefallen hat lassen
bewertung da wenn ich eventuell öfters
mal irgendwas vorlesen soll
lasst auch eine bewertung da schreibt
mir in die kommentare was ihr für bücher
bisher gelesen habt oder ob ihr euch so
ein buch kaufen würde wenn es wirklich
über ein spiel handel bei mir ist es
nämlich so wenn ich habe unglaublich
viel spiel unglaublich viel fifa wenn so
ein buch heraus kommen würde wo
irgendwer sagt so über eine figur die in
fifa quasi drin ist so um ein gottes
bewegte mich nach rechts ich will
endlich nach links laufen ich komme
nicht an den ball irgendwie sowas oder
jetzt auch so was wie hier in minecraft
das ist natürlich mega gau also ja ich
will fahren über die schienen da kaum
skelette blabla so als wenn man wirklich
da drin
das finde ich echt das ist interessant
zu lesen nicht so etwas komisches wie
tauben im gras oder goethe oder
sonderschule das ist nicht sogar ja wie
gesagt lassen bewertung da klickt auf
den link ich habe auch instagram an
facebook alles möglich es steht alles in
der beschreibung jetzt beim wieder beim
nächsten mal wieder was gut und